let's talk a little bit about the state
of maine's mask mandate was lifted this
week
but a state house lawmaker released a
video of herself and her fellow
republicans
being confronted over their refusal to
wear
masks in the capitol after they lifted
the mandate
in order to be in legislative space your
leadership
said that you need to work after you
leave beyond me
i don't care what you do yes you can't
go beyond it
well as a result those seven republicans
have been stripped of their committee
assignments and they were
placed on the committees with democrats
maine stat state representative laurel
libby released that video she was one of
the people there and she joins
us right now lauren good morning to you
laurel rather
good morning thanks for having me you
know i'm just a little mixed up because
the democratic governor of your state
made it very clear no more mass mandate
for everybody in the state except
children age five or older
in school or daycare uh the state house
is not daycare
per se however they're treating you like
kids
yeah exactly steve and more than that
maine people
maine people have been waiting to get
back into their state house which has
been closed for over 14 months
and now to be told that they don't have
to wear a mask anywhere else in the
state
but that to come into their people's
house they have to wear a mask
that just doesn't make any sense we got
a statement from the speaker of the
house
uh ryan fecta who is a democrat he said
we have hundreds of non-partisan workers
in the building who are still required
to wear masks in the workplace
it's the least lawmakers can do to wear
their mask in crowded
indoor common spaces for a few more
weeks i and i don't get the disconnect
between
the speaker and the governor both
democrats
governor says you don't have to wear
them this guy says
you do and you didn't so he stripped you
of your committee assignments
that's outrageous it is it is outrageous
and um to replace us with democrats
makes it clear that it's a political
game
you know and it's funny that you bring
up the non-partisan staff what i noticed
um before the democrats decided to
implement this rule in the state house
i was there i've been there working
since january in my committee room even
though we've been meeting via zoom
and when i was walking around the state
house
after governor mills put in her
executive order that would lift the mass
mandate
and before the legislative council met
um many people were not wearing masks
so it was really an interesting thing
i'm i'm hearing that it's because of the
non-partisan staff but
a couple of those days walking around
the state house you could see that
people were getting really casual with
their mascules
with the um governor's executive order
presumed to be the thing we were going
to be following
well you know it's interesting because
there are there are echoes of
what speaker nancy pelosi a democrat is
doing as well
she's mandating that people wear masks
in the house chambers
meanwhile across the capitol in the
senate you don't have to
and the governor of your state said you
don't have to wear it
you're following the science i'm sure a
lot of the lawmakers have been
vaccinated
ultimately though you could probably
settle this
in court yeah
quite possibly and you bring up you know
following the science that's what we've
been doing for 14 months
and in fact the democrats are so
committed to governor mills making all
the coveted rules that we're still
under an emergency declaration here in
maine
she's still in charge of every other
kova decision except this one
um that they've decided to make their
own rules about
and it probably is going to have to get
decided in court um
it is an ongoing drama it seems and the
the speaker doubled down yesterday
saying that he's not going to follow the
signs he is going to follow
his rule well it is curious and by the
time a court rules
the damage will have been done because
you know your
legislative period is just a certain
length of time and
it's it's a crazy story that's why we
brought you on uh state representative
laurel libby
joining us today from maine good luck
thanks for the update thank you very
much